hey everybody is Jessie and I hope
everyone had a have a good weekend
I spent all most of my weekend on on a
redux reactor Redux project so I think
I'm finally getting the hang of Redux
which is awesome so hopefully there'll
be a Redux project for the live streams
sometime soon
so trying to figure out what the next
project will be after this one which
we're almost finished with and I think
I've realized that I'm actually not that
at Redux
but I'm bad at spelling so that's he
could be more of my problem when I was
trying to debug some of the stuff that
I've been working on I kept thinking I
wasn't I didn't understand Redux but it
wasn't that it was mostly just typos
alright so today's gonna be we're gonna
do about an hour long stream so I have
an appointment coming up a little bit
later on also just a heads up if my wife
calls I'm gonna have to answer it
because she's not feeling well
and she might need help with the kids so
I might have to end the stream earlier
so hopefully that doesn't happen and
she's feeling alright but I it maybe an
abrupt ending here so before we get
started with any code a couple things I
want to show you one is a bow wrote an
article in medium free code camps medium
about how to contribute to the YouTube
channel so if you're interested in
contributing in some way check this out
and really useful stuff on there so
actually as I was reading through this I
was reading about you know what he said
about having a video of
of myself on the on the screen so if you
notice today I do have video of myself
on the screen so I try to make it as
small as possible it wouldn't cover up a
lot of the code I'll try this out I
figure it's worth the shot and it's it's
not like it it's really any extra work
once it's set up the video just appears
so oops I think I accidentally clicked
on something but anyway I just wanted to
share that with you there's a lot of
different ways that you can contribute
if you want to like captioning and
things like that or even creating your
own videos so check that out if you have
a chance also wanted to just do
something fun since we're kind of at the
end of this project I thought it would
be cool to go back and look at where we
started or actually where I started so I
want to show you let's start with this
first so about two years ago almost two
years ago this was I took the screenshot
on October 10th 2015 I'm sorry October
14th 2015 this was the very first
version of the Resource Center and this
version never actually went live like
this they were obviously a lot of
changes but this was the home page so
you can see some of the stuff is similar
we still have a lot of the you know same
options and everything the side menu was
just these these buttons so when you
click this it just brought the buttons
in and out so definitely that's probably
the biggest change other than the colors
we also had the look here's the logo
page so the logo page is a little bit
different we had this this side instead
of every all the options being at the
top I had them down the side service
request form similar we actually had to
split onto two pages and it still had
you know the cool checkbox effect that
that I liked and we had the material
designs
style inputs also you can see definitely
changed up the color scheme a bit this
is a little bit heavy with the gold
color here but but just be cool to kind
of see where we came from and I
definitely learned how to better utilize
these action buttons he's floating
action buttons for material design and I
learned that you shouldn't have a
million of them on the page just one
also here's some sketch mock-ups that I
had done as well so you could see some
alternate designs that I thought of
doing so here's one this was in response
to some feedback that said well people
might not even know that you can click
in these areas right because they just
have the line so I added this kind of
darker background color we I used some
of the alternate colors so here's that
that yellow color that we've been using
as an accent color but as the primary
color this time with kind of actual
outlines around the the fields in the
same way just a little bit different
this is actually somewhat close in color
scheme to what we use now is you know
just this yellow is the accent color
here's an old green and white and here's
lots of gold and then here's a blue
color that's in our color palette so
actually here's the I don't think I've
used this on any projects on the stream
but here's the dark blue and the light
blue that are also in the color palette
and then this is just another alternate
so anyway this is sketched by the way if
you're not if you haven't seen this
before it's it's a cool program to just
do like mock-ups and stuff with designs
I don't I don't use it often usually
just at the beginning of a project
sometimes if I need to show show someone
what I'm thinking and have it be a
little bit better than me just trying to
draw it on a piece of paper then I do it
like that but anyway I found those I had
those at screenshots still saved on my
desktop so I just thought it'd be cool
to check them out
all right so let me check out the live
chat and say hi to everybody before we
get started let's see someone asked
sorry I can't read the name but it says
hi who can recommend SF SFTP / STP
plugin for atom like SFTP for sublime
I'm sorry I don't have I I don't know of
any plugins like that I've never used
any plugins for atom but maybe someone
else in the live chat I may know about
it
peyt hey chase says hi from South Africa
hey how's it going thanks for watching
they have someone from India awesome
thanks I I'm on says I'm too chatty
yeah no I'm no I'm too chatty let's see
all right cool
let me get started oh cool yeah dispute
some more shout outs from where we were
when we said hello from Israel from
Ireland awesome I'm gonna get started
shriek ah s is this project towards the
end yes yes it's it's almost finished
really probably any day now we'll be
we'll be done with it at this point I'm
just kind of waiting for feedback of the
official like yes this is fine we can
launch this and then we'll be done we
might actually start a new project
before this launches because I don't
want to be waiting for feedback and just
doing little updates like even to be
honest with you today's stream I was
having trouble coming up with a title
and a topic for it
because there's not that much left to do
so we're really gonna be I'll show you
my my Trello board this is we're gonna
work on today there's something there's
kind of a weird thing going on with the
cursor when we move over the upload
button so we're going to try to fix that
on small screens that icon that
information icon we have on at this
point only one of our check boxes
overlaps the text so we need to fix that
as well and then if we have time we need
to fix the spacing between some
elements in the form it's just it's not
uniform so but you can see we're getting
down to some things that are just I mean
they're definitely I want to fix but
they're not really like super important
so so we may end up just moving on to
the next project and then you know maybe
I'll come back to this if something
major needs to be changed but if we can
get these three things accomplished I'll
be happy actually if we can just get the
first two accomplished in this stream
I'll be fine with that
let's see so let's go let me show you
what the first thing is so we can get
started on it I'm going to start my
Pomodoro timer and we're gonna do 25
minutes of coding and then five minutes
I'll go back to the live chat and answer
any questions you have we'll probably do
two sessions like that two 25-minute
sessions and then I'll I'll answer any
questions you have before I end the
stream so today we'll just do two
sessions since I have an appointment a
little bit later on see okay so here's
what's what the problem is so you can
see the cursor turns into the you know
the pointer that's let's you know
something's clickable but then once you
get to the middle it changes and then it
goes back so there's this whole area
right in the middle right that huh
interesting
yes so there's there's a large area not
not exactly in the middle right it's
more like it starts here and goes all
the way out so we just I just want to
fix that it's probably going to mean
easy fix
I hope it's gonna be an easy fix but I
just happened to see it at some point
last week and figured you know may as
well this will change it so I want to
try to look at first and see what what
is that element this has got to be
something
hmm button so I'm using of course dev
tools Reggie this is just chrome dev
tools with the dark theme on here and
I'm just kind of going through the
elements here trying to figure out
really I was trying to see if there's
some element that had that basic shape
that we were seeing here with the with
the cursors that we could see the change
I'm not seeing anything with exactly
that shape I do want to see what do we
have with cursor:pointer on it right now
so we have that has the cursor pointer
on it so let's change that let's see
where that's at let's remove it and see
okay so that didn't really affect
interesting let's see if we put it on
here as well no we don't have it on
there okay
cursor points are we have it on this
span let's take that off mm interesting
so I'm going through right now and just
kind of removing it and it's interesting
that there's been no change really
cursor:pointer okay I'm guessing that
this is gonna be the one that really
there we go okay so that's the one that
we're really getting the the pointer
from that's interesting all right so I'm
gonna bring this back so it's
interesting that it works but then
there's something here
we've already seen that these two had
cursor:pointer on them as well now let's
go in here and see oh yeah
ah
so I'm not seeing it not seeing anything
else here this is all oh yeah
interesting
what I'm going to check now then since I
couldn't find anything here obviously in
this div that would be coming over top
of that I'm gonna check this div over
here and I'll probably check this one as
well I just you know what let me I'd
like to change the screen size a bit and
see if that makes a difference because I
think that'll give me a clue as to where
this is coming from if we can find it
oops okay so it's still happening
okay well that's interesting I was
hoping it would be different on a
smaller screen and then that would that
would point me in the right direction
here but it's not while we're here on
the small screen you can see that this
is that that icon that's overlapping so
it should be out here but when we get
down smaller it it overlaps we need to
fix that as well I'll open this up a
little bit again and now now after
seeing what I did on a small screen I
don't think we're gonna have any any
luck by going to these other divs
because the order since the order of
everything kind of changed so this is
above it you know and this one's on the
side but then this one ends up being two
above it and this one is above it
there's nothing on the side I don't
think there's anything in those dips so
I'm not even going to check because
that's um you know probably about 95%
sure there's gonna be a waste of time at
this point so
I think I'd like to try putting
cursor:pointer on this container because
there doesn't seem to be any real reason
why it couldn't be because I
if you click if I click this I don't
even necessarily want it to where you
could just click and potentially I mean
I think I have it yeah you can't type in
there but it looks like you could when
you click it so I don't think I want it
like that anyway so let's make this
whole thing actually just on this one
Hershey's who here
let's see if we can mmm no it's the same
same problem here
interesting
hmm I just happened to look over at the
live chat again Cronus says hello from
Miami Florida I'm stuck in my room
upstairs wow that's that's pretty crazy
how so are you safe there I know they
have if you just in case you don't know
Florida is getting hit with these huge
hurricanes like right more it's pretty
bad so I've seen pictures and video down
there so I hope you're alright
and you're safe down there where you're
at
Wow is it is it really bad in Miami
right now
okay coding and caffeine said maybe the
z-index that's a good idea I was
thinking about that earlier and then I
forgotten okay yeah let's check some
z-index stuff here
yeah the input should actually have the
interesting
there we go there we go check this out
this is our area where we're having the
the problem right here where this says
choose files so that's a problem that's
a problem right there so if we couldn't
see it all right so let's as long as we
can move this out of the way and get rid
of it somehow we should be fine
let's try to change the Z index let's go
this should fix it yep it does mm-hmm
but now we can't upload so that's no
good
all right so we need
okay so there was something I can't
remember what the property is let me
think about this I use this on a project
within the last few months
essentially what what I'm thinking is
there was some sort of property where I
could pass through the clique basically
through to an element that's below and
maybe I'm maybe I'm remembering this
wrong but I thought there was a way that
I could do that
essentially what I'm thinking of doing
is setting this E and X back farther but
then having to see what it was called
let me see if anybody pointer events
there we go
I was thinking click events thank you
John Hanson in the live chat just just
put it in there thank you so much
yeah so it's pointer events let's let's
try this so let's put that Z index back
on here now we have so we have some
stuff over top of it
that we want to set the pointer events
let me do this just wanna do none here
and then below
see now I it's been too long since I've
used this I can't I can't remember how
this may be we have to put this one has
to have four events
no that's not it
okay I have a link wearing shoe put a
link in the live chat and so let me
check this out
I'd rather so I haven't looked at this
yet but it says talking about styling
styling inputs I don't want to I really
don't want to get into styling like too
much because I mean we already have the
styles in here all right let me check
out the live chat now because it seems
like you all are putting a lot of advice
in here so
just thinking so embarrassed I was
thinking of a way to change the div dot
button label for upload try that
position:absolute was the index for one
okay let's we could play with the
z-index a bit and see if we could get it
let's try
all right now I have cursor:pointer on
here but it's not working on it's not
working on it I wonder if there's any
way to force it to work
probably not
yeah I guess
yeah I kind of don't want to do it like
this but this is probably gonna be the
way to go what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
put actually now I don't know if I can
that's all should be on the upper layer
of the C index item was a background on
okay John John Hanson was giving me some
advice on these pointer events
let's see
you should use a label before linking it
to the file input okay
I'm getting I'm getting two different
sets of advice in the in the the live
chat so let me let me pick one we'll try
that out and see if it works now I've
gotten a third or fourth okay I have
quite a few different different paths
here so I'm gonna try the simplest first
and then if it doesn't work I'll move on
and go down down the list
okay so I'll do my best to describe what
what each one is alright so it looks
like the simplest suggestion to try
would just be let's go back to here
appearance none
okay not working
yes okay so that did not work I
jarvez suggested that thank you for the
suggestion let me know if I did I
implemented that wrong but right now
it's not working okay I'll move on to
let's let's try this label so the next
suggestion is make a label for the for
the file for the input so let's try this
so let me see if I can I assume that I
guess I shouldn't assume it but I was
assuming that one of these also has a
label on here but I guess not oh well
here we go
but is this even doing it alright let's
put this
so is it possible
whoops and the four the four goes with
the name correct and not the
alright not working good okay I'm bear
to assist it does get with the ID all
right I wasn't sure it's one of those
things that I really I rarely do this on
like by hand you know there's always
some sort of framework or you just copy
and paste the examples so it's been it's
been quite a while
feel like the only time I actually do
this form inputs by hand as if I'm doing
like tutorial exercises or something
okay Fars ID okay
all right let me try this looks like you
need a label not a div yeah that's what
I was thinking haha Robin says so is
being a developer copy and paste not
exactly
it doesn't vote copy and pasting but
that's not all alright let's see in
class button alright let's take this off
of here for now
let's make those
a whole nice
okay so that works definitely want to
okay great alright so that works now I
wanted it to be so that if you clicked
over here you could also upload so let's
just try to put that over here yeah
let's try to change that make this the
label instead
and see if we can get that to work
mmm now it looks like that's not working
let's see oh okay
so when I change this to label it
definitely changed some of what was
going on here so let's see okay
all right well at least we have the
full-width but it's still hey there we
go so it is if you saw that so I did
click out here somewhere and it worked
there you go so basically we have this
this kind of covering things up right
now so let's yeah let's go
all right Susie index is not working for
that now let's see
see if we can go back to our pointer
events all right
great and let's make sure it's awesome
okay so that works so my my timer just
went off as well so this is good timing
so let me just explain what what ended
up working so we we made a label of this
div here that was basically just a
container div that span this entire area
so we turn this into a label with a four
attribute that matched the ID of our
input right so that's big I mean that's
nothing really groundbreaking right
that's just like basic HTML how this
works right you click the label and it
activates the input so we did that we
made sure that we put cursor:pointer on
this so that we got that that cursor
everywhere the problem was that this was
acting like a like a text area which we
don't want to act exactly like a text
area we don't want it to seem like you
could click in there and type we wanted
when you click on this for the file
upload to be activated so we had to go
down here to where this wrapper is for
that for that text area and there we
added our pointer events none so we
actually ended up combining several of
approaches that you all suggested in the
live chat which is pretty cool and it
all worked so now so far we've only done
this in dev tools so let me go over to
the actual code and do this and then
I'll do my five minutes of answer
questions in the live chat I just don't
want to forget this in the five minutes
that I answer questions so let's go over
to the code and change this so our
service requests thought I had a service
request for them open here there we go
so it is open here let's see where
upload is here we go
okay so this was what we turned into a
label
let's make this a label
who's that
there we go
all right so there's our label we also
needed to change this there we go we
needed to change this to display:block
because when we added the label then it
was no longer display:block so we needed
that we need to we need to add the
upload nor the before okay upload so
that's it through for this area right
foot didn't we need to put
cursor:pointer I think we did let's do
that as well there's a pointer and down
here
for a file path wrapper okay we already
have it here for a file path wrapper we
need to do pointer events none all right
let's try that out
save that and we'll save that and let's
just give it a hard refresh make sure
you clear out everything here in dev
tools
okay so let's whoops
oops I forgot we needed to put make the
z-index for this input nothing we had a
negative one so if we go file field I
think this is the only input so I think
we're safe to just say input here
there we go okay so now we have our
pointer over this whole thing we click
it great we get that
let's awesome alright cool so mission
accomplished on that one and that took
it did take a little over one Pomodoro
session but since I was trying to
narrate what I was doing at the same
time I think we'll leave it at one all
right great
let me turn on my five-minute timer and
I'm gonna go through the live chat and
see what what questions you all have see
all right so I'm going all the way up to
the top
taught tough fix it says wish your wife
quick recovery thank you so much
I if you weren't here at the beginning I
mentioned that my wife's not feeling
well so I may have to if she needs me I
may have to end the stream and go help
out with the kids but so far so good but
thank you I appreciate you saying that
Mau Mau Russa says you guys are awesome
thank you I appreciate that
oh cool
I can't I'm sorry so I remember having
trouble with this name last time because
it's not I wanted to say Brian but I
don't think it was Brian Bri a I and I'm
really sorry I usually can remember but
this one I couldn't remember so let me
know what let me know how it was I know
I eventually got it right so please let
me know how to pronounce that properly I
don't want to mess it up anymore but
anyway he said I liked the last examples
of the sketch mock-ups I don't remember
what the last one was let me see okay so
I'm guessing it's it's this one the last
example with all the colors so cool
thanks yeah I kind of I thought it was
cool I actually think it would be cool
to do to have like a little Easter Egg
in the in the the site somewhere to
where you could just change the colors
up so it wouldn't really be that obvious
that you could do it but if you if you
searched around enough you'd be able to
toggle all the colors that'd be cool if
I had a lot of time if maybe I would do
that
Shandra asks which text editor do you
recommend I use plugins for code editor
I use atom and I would recommend atom I
like it but I also like Visual Studio
code so those two I have actually used
and would recommend I can't personally
recommend anything else because I
haven't really there's nothing else that
I've used in really light but I have
heard that sublime is is pretty good and
for people who know them it's really
cool and they they really like it I when
I see people use them I'm always really
impressed with it but the learning
curves a little bit higher than
something like like atom sublime
notice we have Marcus it's a loaf from
Serbia hey how's it going
Nova blue asked what editor are you
using I'm using Adam Srikant says we'll
ask the new project also be react
I don't know so actually this let me
know what you all think we've done so
far we've done to react projects would
you really like another react project
you like something else I'm gonna tell
you let me tell you what's what's up so
I talked to my boss this morning to try
to figure out what the priorities are in
terms of the projects that are that I
know I'm gonna have to work on at some
point you know in this this year that I
thought that we would have a project
it'd be a good candidate for react and
maybe even redux but it turns out that
that's not really a higher priority I
thought it was a higher priority than it
was so that can wait and might not even
it might be more towards like the end of
the year like December so for the
immediate future so basically for this
month for September the main website for
Franciscan edu needs some work but it
doesn't need it's not gonna be react not
yet I'm eventually gonna redo that site
completely and react but for right now I
don't think I can dedicate the time to
that although I'd love to redo it so for
right now it's probably just gonna be me
going through we currently exists and
trying to make it better so cleaning up
the UI trying to make it faster where I
can mainly by you know getting rid of
unused code and kind of eliminating a
lot of the the image it's really image
heavy right now and I think
unnecessarily so trying to cut down on
that just making things look a lot more
clean I mean you all kind of probably
know my style by now that I like things
to be really clean minimal but here's
the thing though that's going to be
on project because it's already built
using a content management system called
Ektron which is dotnet framework based
so I'm gonna be working in like C sharp
like dotnet templates and stuff and I'm
gonna be working with just straight like
HTML CSS it's going to be really
different than what I've done before so
I'm actually I'm a little bit nervous I
don't know if that how well that would
go down but that's probably going to be
first priority for the month of
September if there's some if there's
some other way that I could do a project
and just spend like an hour a day on
this project when I did the stream and
then the rest of the day I can work on
the main web site that might be possible
as well but I'd like to know what you
all think I mean if you'd like to switch
it up and do something that's not react
and instead do something that's like
dotnet I mean that's that's fine with me
I just want to make sure that if it's
possible for me to do something that's
more relevant to you all then I'd like
to do it you know obviously it's not
completely in my control because I got
to work on whatever you know my boss
tells me to work on but within that the
freedom that I have on my projects I'd
like to show you all what you want to
see so anyway let me know about that my
5 minutes is up for this for this
session I'm going to start another
Pomodoro session right now and then I'll
get through the rest of the live chat I
realized I didn't get through that much
of it so I'll just have to get through
some more on the next time but anyway
let me know think about it and let me
know the only other project that I
probably could work on is I have I have
to work with Salesforce so there's like
an application that we have for students
who are interested in coming here they
want to apply to go here that's all
built through Salesforce and they have I
think it's called like eight
basically it's it's kind of like their
templating system it was described to me
is like some somewhat like JavaScript
I'm not really sure that I don't really
know if the person on the phone
describing this was a developer or if
they were sales so I don't really know
how accurate this is but basically there
was something that Salesforce uses
that's they sold me if you know
JavaScript you'll be able to do this so
I don't know a lot about it but I know
it's gonna be mostly CSS stuff
occasionally maybe I'll go in and change
some of the templates but to be honest
with you right now I was checking out
earlier today and I don't even know
where to find the template so I'm gonna
need to do some more research on that
that's also going to be kind of a weird
project where I'm going to be working
kind of inside this other system to try
to do it you know I won't be able to set
it up exactly like I want to I'll just
have to kind of work with what's there
and change it so anyway so just let me
know what you all think about those
projects if you're interested in
anything or you know any other ideas for
now though I'm gonna go back and do some
work I just not realized I had this
still up on the screen I wonder if
anybody just tuned in and like saw these
really what what is going on with change
of this project how I covered that up
and it means you alright so let's do
another Pomodoro session let's see
what's next up on here so fix the
checkbox
all right let's fix this one I already
showed you a little bit earlier what was
wrong with it I can show you again in
case you didn't see it before but check
check this one out in that icon when we
move over it overlaps
all right that's that's no good it also
overlaps at another point here so
we need to fix that and I may have to
just come up with some other way to
position this other than what we're
doing now and I'll show you what we're
what we're doing with it okay so that
checkbox now I've made its own component
and I just call it an icon checkbox so
if you are following along with what
we're doing on github that's in the
components folder you can look at ICON
checkbox j/s and that's where we're at
so right now I just have some inline
Styles on that and or actually just
position positioning this with absolute
positioning so it shouldn't have been
that much a surprise to me whatever the
positioning was messed up usually when
you try to use absolute positioning like
that and you want your site to be
responsive it doesn't work quite like
you wanted to
unless you're positioning something like
in the in the corners usually the
corners worked fine but things in the
middle of the page don't work out at
least that's been my experience so I'm
thinking there's we could either do two
things I could try to work with the
existing breakpoints and change these
values based on that I'm not really
excited about doing that that just seems
like it doesn't seem to me like the best
solution the other solution would be to
not use absolute positioning try to use
try to do it some other way so that it
wouldn't matter at all what the screen
size is it's always gonna be at the end
of that line so let's um let's see what
we can do let's mess around with it here
in dev tools a bit and I mean maybe
we'll have to change the mark-up it will
change how I was working in the in HTML
somebody's just zoom in a bit so we can
see and I can move this off to the side
here
let's make it there we go
so there's the overlap so I mean
obviously we could like I said we could
just shift it around but here's here's
what I don't think that'll work
it's not a good solution also because I
want to keep this component reusable
right so there could be it could just
say photography in that case the way
we're positioning and now it might not
be a bad thing we'll just shift the
positioner on but also it could be
really long so I guess what we want then
is we wanted always to appear at the end
and I suppose even wrap this wrap around
it does yeah so even if this wrapped
around I guess we would still wanted to
appear at the end it won't look great
but better that's better than
overlapping the only other way that I
can think of changing it that I know for
sure would work all the time I guess
would be to move the icon to the
beginning but I don't really think that
would look I don't think that would look
right I guess we could try it but let's
see if we can do it a different way and
then as as a last resort we could
probably just move this up here and then
we'll know that it'll always work
because it'll be right at the beginning
excuse me sad too heady on okay
all right so let's see
I think our problem
yeah let's go back to here and let me
show you so the problem before that we
were having was that I was trying to put
this checkbox or this icon inside the
the label right so I was trying to pass
that in as a prop so basically the the
text with an SVG in line I was going to
pass it all in and I think we're having
trouble with that and then I think it
was I think of the Sebastian submitted a
pull request where he came up with doing
it away similar to this and then I
changed it a bit turned it into its own
component and then switched to this
style of positioning so I kind of
figured I mean ideally I would be able
to pass it all in here I but I guess I
have to be honest with you I can't even
remember I'd have to go back and watch
the video you did this I can't remember
if it just totally failed and it
wouldn't work at all or for it just
wasn't working exactly how we wanted it
to
see but in any case that's why we we
have these separated out so then you see
when it comes out you know here there's
this whole container div you know with
all this stuff in here and then next to
that we have this other div that has our
image
display table
that's interesting
let's mess around here's what I'm
thinking right now what if we could take
these two container divs and have them
display side-by-side
alright let's just I'm just gonna mess
around a little bit here just with some
of these properties and see what we get
I need to reset some of this
position of my getting
with this to be actually let's get rid
of a lot of this stuff
when it comes to this kind of thing
that's just okay I don't mind that now
we may still have the same problem we
get that's it okay I guess not
this might just might not be a bad way
to fix it if I can get them both on the
same line
okay
all right I think I'm gonna check I have
an idea but I'm gonna check the live
chat first see if you all have a better
idea
oh okay just saw one there we go thank
you
who's that Carlos Carlos thank you so
much that's exactly what the problem was
all right for a second there I thought I
forgot how CSS works I had with a
hundred percent that's why all this
stuff I was going with position and
floats we're not working awesome okay so
let's try this out we're just gonna move
it back and forth of bed okay not mmm
not terrible let's get rid of this float
all right that's better
yeah I kind of like that better we just
did
oh yes
I like that better
okay this is what I'd so here's a tip
you probably already know this but if
you want to make your screen even
smaller than it already is
just make your console dock or your dev
tools docked and then you can shrink it
down really small like smaller than
normal I wanted to do this just to see
obviously not no one's ever gonna be
looking at it like that but I just
wanted to see what would happen if we if
this went on to another line mm-hmm okay
not bad let's just give this a lot more
text and see what happens
there we go
oops
yeah okay
it looks like it it's not bad like this
but once we get down smaller then it's
not great
I guess I'm okay with it for now since
we I think this is the longest one that
we have yeah I'm okay with it
it's not perfect but for our use case
right now it definitely works if we end
up getting longer ones that need that
need this then then I can worry about
that at that point okay
let's see
anyway Hamza says you won't be going
smaller than 320 pixels with ya for sure
the only reason I wanted to go smaller
was I just wanted to see like let's say
we had something that was really long I
just want to try to simulate what would
happen and then after I thought well why
don't I just put the text in there so
that's why I was this was a better way
to do it just adding more text
originally I just didn't think about
that but you're right yeah nothing's no
screen that I know of is smaller than
320 pixels and with all right so let's
just do this in our code so you end up
having this div
well
and my mind block should work yeah
okay
I'm gonna have to get to that div with
with this CSS there's no
I don't think there's any way just rush
I wonder which style I'm passing down
let's check out our service request
let's find our checkboxes style star
checkbox it's trying to track down where
our styles are here we go okay so we do
have checkboxes here let's see what that
margin bottoms being applied here great
okay so whatever we put there with our
margin bottom should work should be fine
[Music]
we don't want we don't want with 100%
let's go with with Auto ok Auto words
so the width auto float:left and I guess
we'll do this I can't remember with the
default display was an English blog so
we'll do display:inline-block with Auto
float:left
alright forget that one down and now
this next one whoa
okay that was definitely not the right
thing to do what did I do
all right let's see
is it the float
I was further with
maybe
that's odd
I don't think I change anything else
let's see
all right let's let's get rid of these
for now
let's see what we had okay so if it was
display table before
mm-hmm all right and they like to think
about something different all right I
was checking the live chat to see if I
missed anything
okay all right
let's see what it
yeah let me see
that this week this
okay
maybe if I move this styles into I could
maybe try to move this into our icon
check box component and then depending
on whether or not there's an icon I can
have different styles
that works
yeah I guess first I did I just need to
test see if I could do this twice on two
different checkboxes I'm guessing that
it wouldn't work it like let's say I did
it on two different checkboxes right
next to each other and have the same
weird stuff happening so I guess it
wouldn't matter either way
let's see if I can
I've never seen this max content min
content before I want to try to keep
this display table now and then set the
width Auto and see what happens
maybe I'll have a different result than
I did before
what was that I'm just gonna not set the
display
now that that was the width thing ice I
guess is what the problem is
we got to give it some sort of with I
guess alright let's let's do let's give
it a hundred percent with but minus the
width of the icon so let's see how how
big our icon is
so icon yeah
so like 24 pixels it's just the Sade
let's give it 25 so let's let's give our
with 100% - 25 pixels see what that does
okay better now
now we can do this
why is it going all the way up there
okay
okay thank you know live jet okay
flexstretch is with my default a place
automatically without any descending
with
[Music]
all right eyes huh good some said said
what's this sorcery in the in the hole
I've said
yeah it's yes okay so John Hanson is
saying we can use flex display flex and
then justify content space between
alright let's try that out because I I'm
thinking like I ain't hurtin Lee did
something right me I don't know why this
is now appearing way up at the top I'm
trying to do it over here because I
floated everything left
interesting
there we go
and
see
all right let me try out this
I want to show off this flex thing that
John's talking about but basically we I
thought this might end up being tricky
because I remember when I messed with it
last time it was it was a little bit
tricky which is why I end up going with
what I did
alright so John's saying dude display
flex and then justified content space
between so flex
so are we putting it on here then let's
try it up
oops
whoa
okay
all right let me see whoa all right I
lost track of time a bit let's let's
stop here so I can get to some questions
and then I have to get to my appointment
and let me let me check let me scroll up
now but to get to the last place where I
left off in the live chat so sorry we're
not gonna be able to finish this right
now I feel like we're really close it's
just a matter of figuring out what the
best way is that that is going to work
for the screen sizes I think we have
maybe at least two possible solutions
that that I can think of right now that
will work I'll just have to finish those
up tomorrow I need to check I need to
check on traffic though to make sure I
can get to my appointment on time
because they're doing construction on
the highway on the way there so alright
it's telling me okay it'sit's it looks
like traffic's not bad right now so I
should be able to answer some questions
and still be alright to get there
let's see
it's trying to find where I left off
okay I think I found it yeah it's the
last thing we were talking about was
what the next project would be okay so
I'm ash asked about a quick briefing on
what I'm building so ash not sure if
you're still watching but I guess I can
quick click update for Astra for anyone
else that's watching and wasn't sure
what we're building this is just a react
react site that allows users to submit
requests and upload files and then those
get sent to a project management system
through their API and the files get
uploaded to our server which we're
running a droplet on digitalocean
with node and nginx is a reverse proxy
and users can also just get some other
resources and some basic information
download some images so it's not really
that involved probably the the most
complicated thing we're doing here is
handling file uploads and form data
okay so at some point nova glow had said
but aren't you only doing client-side
editing the moment you refresh the pager
where it goes away yes that's true and
it looks like no glow got some answers
as well but I'll explain this just in
case anyone else is having that that
can't see the live chat I was thinking
the same thing when you edit things in
dev tools yes they're not by default
they're not permanent you can set it up
so that your project files actually can
be edited through dev tools it's really
cool I just never took the time to set
that up but for now it's just a really
fast way to see what's going on make
some changes and I don't like to do a
lot I don't like to do more than I can
remember
because then you're right if you refresh
the page then you lose it all so I like
to do a little bit see if it works and
then transfer it over to my files and
then kind of go back and forth like that
I just uh-huh um so just says what I see
your face yes if you can see my face
it's kind of odd if I keep doing it like
this I might I might switch and get a
different camera I'm just using the
built-in camera on an iMac and the angle
is weird like I just feel like it keeps
getting a shot of my forehead all the
time and you can't really see my facial
expressions so I think it would be
better if the camera angle were a little
bit lower so I don't know maybe I'll
keep a lookout for any webcams that are
on sale rude rude rang Shu says can
anyone recommend me one of among the
following so amber Jas Orillia Jas and
polymer Jas I'm sorry I don't have
experience with those I mean I I know
what they are
I've read about them but I don't have
hands-on experience I don't really feel
qualified to make a recommendation so
hopefully there are some other people in
the live chat that can can recommend
something to you
oh cool Blake said said hey I like the
face preview awesome cool maybe oh uh
maybe I'll keep it as long as I was
afraid it would block too much of the
code but it didn't seem to be a problem
so as long as it's not a problem I'm
fine with with leaving it there okay
see Daryl asks react native versus
PhoneGap and got a suggestion to use
react native from word rang shoo yeah I
um I also recommend react native all
right I got to answer the door so I'll
be right back
okay yeah I recommend react native as
low I phone gaps been around for a while
and I don't have personal experience
with react native yet I will soon but
from what I've from what I've read about
it if I had to say I'd say good with
react native but like I said I don't
have hands-on experience with it
okay so it'sit's Brean so earlier I'd
asked for clarification on how to
pronounce a name so it's is it is it
Bria no Driscoll is that it let me know
if that's I'm pretty sure that's what
that's what is supposed to be okay I was
I was talking about editors earlier and
Nova blow says Emacs is better than them
Patrick says Emacs evil mode is better
than Emacs I don't know what that is
oh and brains of M user as well cool
çf coder - says what responds to the
framework are you using doesn't appear
to be bootstrap it's material UI but
Bharat says so is there any project on
Salesforce you'll be working on yeah
actually I do have something that I need
to I'm gonna work on in Salesforce so
maybe I'll be doing that on the the
livestream I'm not sure yet we'll see I
don't know we'll see how it goes I still
haven't decided what project I'd like to
try to stick with the project I mean I
could bounce back and forth and do like
two different projects at once but I
don't want it to be confusing I mean I
could I could put them a different
playlist name them you know different
things but I'm undecided yet as to
exactly what the next project will be
okay all right I'm kind of going through
a lot and just looking for any questions
especially from new people because I'm
gonna have to leave here in just a
minute
okay
all right so I'm gonna end with this
John Hanson said I could put a green
screen behind me so that my background
would be transparent you just see me act
that would be really cool I but I don't
know about having a green screen in my
office yet we have a video studio that's
it's actually right on the other side of
the wall from my office and there's a
huge green screen that they use in there
but they're always filming something in
there so I don't think they'd let me do
my streams in there I don't know I'll
see maybe they have some leftover green
green stuff that I can hang that would
be fun all right well I got a oh
actually here's one more question
Hamza said have you watched noob cat on
Twitch I haven't watched her live yet I
didn't I didn't get a chance we I talked
to her on Twitter before which was
really cool she she had written an
article about live-streaming and I let
her know how helpful that was for me and
it was really who she was really
encouraging for my stream and said said
nice things about it so I really want to
be able to watch her live at some point
I'm just the time for me just doesn't
work out but anyway I think from a
little bit that I've seen in the stream
it's awesome so alright so I gotta take
off I got a good two to an appointment
now and thanks for watching
I really kind of hoped we'd get more
done I really I actually really wanted
to like combine the sass files and
organize them a bit but it just didn't
didn't work out today so I'll be back
tomorrow assuming my wife doesn't get
any worse and then I might have to take
a day off and take care of the kids but
otherwise I should be back tomorrow and
thank you so much for watching in for
all your help
I really appreciate it and have a great
day